da ist er der gute herr ich glaube wir
verlieren
jo leute was geht hier ist euer kran ii
und heute spiele ich war überhaupt oder
krank
das fragte ich gerade
höchstwahrscheinlich ich spiele heute
auf dem kanal von ex-champion ich bin
übrigens sein bruder fest dass manche
von euch vielleicht noch nicht wissen
der coole bruder übrigens also ihr wisst
was du tun musst abonniert man kann
wann und ob auf jeden fall können
natürlich noch richtig drauf gerade wir
haben kurz am 9
und ich nehme dieses video ist so
schnell auf weil der liebe es aber
höchstwahrscheinlich wissen gerade auf
seine gangster trip und es gerade in
hamburg und hat dort kein internet das
heißt er kann kein video hochladen also
keinen block video hoch ich bin dumm wie
excel das ändern am kit gerät und lud
alle kisten damit nicht richtiger im
kopf verdammt ich glaube das könnte
schwierig werden jetzt hier noch
irgendwas zu reißen
aber man soll den tag nicht vor dem ihr
wisst schon
und deshalb problem ist unser glück und
irgendwie lag das hier leichtfertig
gefühl beschreibt pc also ich will ja
auch am pc von escape deshalb auch das
flugzeug in sandstedt aber werfen kann
zudem dürfen wir eigentlich schon mal
die sie kriegen geht auf jeden fall
rüstung freunde irgendwie ist dass das
ganze ein bisschen habe ich gefühlt sind
die blöcke erscheinen immer nicht da ist
immer nur was transparentes außen rum wo
eigentlich die blöcke erscheinen sollten
den 1
trotzdem sind wir noch nicht
es liegt irgendwie wie kot hier tut mir
leid ich weiß aber nicht woran es liegt
weil das ja nicht mal mein pc s uplink
probieren wir zu prägen den haben wir
gekriegt vielleicht ein bisschen
abgestaubt würden jetzt die hater sagen
aber hey das mac infamous und ich hab
jetzt für mich also ich hab selbst ewig
kein display mehr eigentlich so richtig
aufgenommen
also was ist lässt blake einen drin
montag ich mag es aber eigentlich auch
aber irgendwie denke ich mir also falls
jetzt dass auch leute von mir sehen so
die anderen die nur meinen bruder schon
denke ich jetzt wahrscheinlich weiter
schwach ich bin gerade noch ein bisschen
amex probieren wir andere spiele zu
spielen so ein schiff und deshalb ist es
gerade sehr schön
ich habe auch bock darauf aber es ist
halt schon ein bisschen unkreativ nicht
immer jeden tag zum runden papier liegt
vielleicht auch daran dass ich als 700
videos gemacht habe und davon sind
wahrscheinlich 650 mindestens einfach
stumpf pvp aber jetzt habe ich damit zu
wobei womit sonst droht aber nicht mal
hier ich kann ja nicht viel erzählen vom
trip von meinem bruder und dem lieben
adrian wenn du's wendel sich auch schon
kennengelernt
aber dafür brauche ich nicht viel
erzählen dass er war es gar nicht mal so
falsch dass ich hier in chat aus meinem
leben ein bisschen geschichten aus dem
leben was ihr euch das erzählt habe
siehst du es ist mein glaube ich oder es
müsste jetzt mal eine richtige asi okay
aber alter
ok eines runtergefallen demps an
das ist irgendwie relativ gut was wir
gerade machen premier den auch noch
steht trotzdem nur zwei herzen
okay aber irgendwie bin ich das nicht
ganz gewöhnt hier zu spielen
ja aber auch erst vier minuten daher
nehmen eine große runde
die nehmen wir noch mit freude und
wieder ändern geht das irgendwann fällig
wenn man kommt echt so schnell die mitte
dass man sich easy dass das andere kind
widmen zusammen luton kann wenn man sich
nicht dumm anstellt aber hier niemand
sagt dass ich mich nicht und stelle
daher gewiss schon kann das ins auge
gehen so wo ist die mitte davor nicht
glaubt er braucht aber noch ein paar
blicke mehr als die die ich jetzt hier
habe bei 26 aber es wird auch schon
knackig naja mal sehen ob er jetzt
wahrscheinlich unendlich viele kisten in
der mitte wenn wir so eine 16er runde
spielen man sehen ob es überhaupt lang
könnte lang probiert es einfach mal
aber ich denke doch st danke schön ist
ja diesmal punkt wer kann dazu gar nicht
sagen ich baue ich selber ganz stumpf in
die mitte nach vorne und ich muss sagen
es ist irgendwie ein bisschen gästen ist
nicht geheuer aber irgendwie lag
obwohl sebastian mag ich habe den
besseren pc stimmt vielleicht auch aber
trotzdem wieder brauchen wir sogar noch
ein bisschen mehr platz aber die runde
könnte ziemlich lange werden wenn ich
das so sehe also 16 spieler mit so einer
krassen distanzen die mitte
mal sehen vielleicht haben wir aber auch
einfach glück und kriegen irgendwie ein
haufen ender perlen oder sowas
es wäre definitiv nicht falsch diesmal
ist geschafft freunde aber die schutz
jetzt auch direkt zu ende weshalb
wir wenn wir einigermaßen gute kämpfe
ist am besten direkt anziehen was jetzt
hat auch getan habe jo mei la perle
damit sind wir schon nicht mehr gefangen
beziehung zu lösen ist weg bauen hier
dieser bitte ermittle inmitten von
metten wird die mitte in die luft
sprengen habe ich mich gerade
entschieden einfach als cooles sache in
die luft zu sprengen
so einen guten sachen eine gute sache
aber wohin
klicke ich freue mich hier ein bisschen
weg deshalb also aus welchen luft
schwimmen
ich freue mich hier ein bisschen weg
dass ich dann dahin kann und dann
springt einfach die ganze mit in die
luft einfach weil ich es kann
fitch ist so ok ok ok ok das tief lag
auch wenn bisschen wegfliegen die teile
auf nummer sicher hier nochmal das nicht
und wahrscheinlich kommen schreiben es
1000 menschen rasch vergessen wird das
neue der mitte mitteln können aber ich
lege mir egal
mir egal ich bin irgendwie ein bisschen
fröhlich aber so schön wie
selbstgespräche schauen wir uns das
spektakel aus der distanz an
jetzt wird wahrscheinlich niemand mehr
für nötig halten in die mitte zu gehen
und das ist schlau weil sonst laufen
alle leuten die mitte und so kann man
einfach ganz gemütlich die inseln
abklappern
wenn man nicht der forschungsstelle was
ich mir gut vorstellen kann aber den
abend nicht glauben so gilt das
sprichwort etwas anders behauptete zum
gegner nach links ist der nächste gegner
aber das hier ist noch von mir das heißt
das ist dort unten eine kiste gibt die
ständig geöffnet habe na ja einigermaßen
gutes zeug ganz auf jeden fall mal hier
das restliche reisen kräften schaffen
science da kann es auch mal ein schwert
machen sogar dass es noch ein ticken
besser als unser jetziges schwert plus
eine hose die verzaubern wir noch direkt
auch noch mal wobei das bringt schon
hier protection oder anbrechen
es klingt eigentlich genau genommen
nichts also natürlich schon ein bisschen
was aber nicht so heftig wie aber wir
versuchen es trotzdem wie cars we can
ok noch können wir gar nichts aber jetzt
können wir so ein damit und protection
selbst relativ unwahrscheinlich dass man
dass man hier schaffens kriegt aufweisen
schwert zumindest unwahrscheinlich als
bei gold beziehungsweise stein the water
[ __ ] das ist richtig gut
12 ich glaube ich habe auch nur zwei
level gebraucht oder eigentlich nur ganz
schnell geklickt aus versehen
aber das wasser den verwehrt weil das
ist ein relativ selten dass man schaffen
es zwei kriegt direkt als venture mit
heftig dann könnte man ja das kann ich
mir dann auch mit dem dia schwert
kriegen nämlich sachsens kann niemand
mehr in die mitte und das erste was ich
mache ist
mit dem kopf
ich bin heute dumm aber trotzdem finde
ich sehr fancy macht er jetzt macht er
diese ich hoffe mal wirft es nicht mit
irgendwelchen sachen rund nämlich ein
großer vertrauensbruch
aber hier mit der ange kommst du mich
mein freund feder der später nimmt for
life und kann er natürlich also viel
machen
fans dieser ziemlich dumm
dafür wird jetzt seine insel in die luft
gesprengt
ich liebe das leute das macht viel zu
viel spaß
ich will so mensch der das allererste
mal minecraft spiel einfach direkt alles
in die luft während prinz war das damals
als diese erst mal gespielt habe das
alles im griff gehabt habe hat euch das
interessiert schreibt es in die
kommentare
die richtung ist der nächste da ja nicht
in der mitte ist wie es wahrscheinlich
ist es ein gutes stück wahrscheinlich
sie sehen nur noch zwei spieler ja dann
werde ich es höchstwahrscheinlich meine
and appelle an einwänden meine perle
einsetzen
guck mal das hat auch so rote ränder
diese ganzen texturen irgendwie ist das
texture pack glaube ich nicht so sauber
deshalb liegt wahrscheinlich auch dass
er tut und er ist full full dir das
heißt wir wahrscheinlich relativ schwer
zu finden aber das heißt natürlich nicht
dass wir es nicht versuchen wir sind
immerhin wir das war die pure zitiert
mich auf tumblr aber gespräche die
quelle an
ich hab nicht mehr tabu ich habe glaube
ich war auch noch nie auf tumblr wobei
doch ich war schon öfters mal auf der
seite von
warum jetzt direkt das auf tumblr seiten
von irgendwelchen menschen
und dann habe ich das nicht gecheckt
sowie twitter habe ich einfach auch
nicht gecheckt 3 milliarden metern
abstand meine lieblings plattform können
wir überraschen
höchstwahrscheinlich aber nicht okay da
ist er der gute herr ich glaube
verlieren
ich finde wenn ich darf man träumen
können die noch immer welche trenkel
hacker strecke sind verboten in dem
spiel
ich glaube das weiß er genauso gut wie
ich also gar nicht wtf tja mein freund
noch hingefallen bin komplett änderte am
endpoint
besser tablette ist alles mit hatte
angst ich finde probieren ihn laut braun
zu sehr stören
oh gott oh gott wie basic widmen aber
ich habe 1000 herzen krass aber gute
idee vielleicht sieht er das video dann
bei service geschafft habe haha das
unsportlich hh zu schreiben aber das was
man heute macht gut bis zum nächsten mal
und tschüss